hey francis do you like books uh only
when they have pictures all the
waterproof ones i can take in the bath
with me all right well for those of you
who can read and enjoy reading satire in
particular we have just the book for you
what's that shut up the book is called
woke fragility it's a brilliantly funny
takedown of robin d'angelo's white
fragility and woke culture more
generally it will keep you amused
through the small wee hours a
civilization collapses all around you
it's satire as it's meant to be allowing
you to laugh at things the powers that
be have now deemed off limits we all
know that comedy now is more toothless
than joe biden after he's removed his
dentures this is what you need to hit
the funny bone in these demented times
and it's received an average of 4.4
stars on amazon if you've already read
work for agility then tired moderate
also has two other books out the little
book of work jokes and scary stories to
tell the world in the dark woke parody
of scary stories to tell in the dark
i'll read that book which one the little
one
find his books on amazon and enjoy a
satirical book that's funny and playful
you must know as someone who used to
work in politics how toxic what you've
just said is but someone's got to say it
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is the
author of among the mosque professor
hussein welcome to trigonometry thank
you for having me it's a great pleasure
to have you we've had a bit of a chat
before the interview started and i can
already feel this is going to be a
really interesting and important
conversation before we get into it
though tell everybody a little about who
you are how
how are you where you are i've messed up
that question twice now
and what has been your journey through
life that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us well my journey started
here in london i was born here
to parents who came from two different
countries one from arabia another that
was then british india they came here in
the 1950s so family's been here for
decades but i migrated to the united
states of america where i teach at
georgetown university but i'm british
i'm proud of my country i love my
country and therefore i come back often
and i keep a close eye on on all things
here i went to school in east london i
then went and studied
history and
middle eastern studies at the school of
oriental and african studies
during my early years i got caught up in
what's today described as extremism i
you know i think an older generation
came to political maturity through
communism my generation of young muslims
growing up in this country came to
political maturity through what we call
islamism you know the the politicization
i think the the
bastardization of a faith you know
there's making it all politicized and
making it all confrontational
so i was involved with a range of
organizations you know
hamas which is now banned which was then
allowed i was
involved with those guys as well as
hezbollah the muslim brotherhood and
others i saw the light very quickly i
saw how shallow they were i left them
and i then went and studied arabic and
sharia in the middle east in syria and
saudi arabia the 7th of july 2005
bombings happened my sister missed one
of the bombs by about four minutes and
was too close to home i came
back to britain and i wrote a book
called islamist that did very well and
then i
helped set up a think tank and then i
moved to america the council on foreign
relations at the height of the arab
spring got involved in
some of the governments there and
advising on how best to govern but also
what some of the mistakes that the
islamist organizations were making
particularly the muslim brotherhood
and then i came back to britain because
tony blair
and i had a certain rapport in
approaching counter-terrorism and
approaching the way in which the middle
east ought to be governed
and then i
started reading more of roger scrutin's
works and i did a phd under sir roger
scrooge and god rest his soul and i
benefited immensely from his knowledge
and the way in which he saw the world
and then i returned to america and uh
i'm there now but i come here too so
that's the long and short of it and
we're delighted to have you and what
what an interesting intellectual journey
that that that is
you know being radicalized somewhat and
then not and then tony blair and roger
scrutin very different people and to be
influenced by both i suppose look before
we get into the book
let's just we've talked about this
before and i think most of our audience
understand the difference between
muslims and islamists and all of that
but since we're having this conversation
with you fresh
can you just explain to people because i
think a lot of ordinary people who don't
have the time or the inclination frankly
to get into all of this deeply
sometimes they can they can be
conflation or misunderstanding so can
you just separate this out for us uh so
that we we would start from a good place
i think the best analogy constantine is
to look at china the average chinese
person is not evil
they they're they're culturally chinese
they have you know cultural traits and
they're good human beings as most human
beings are but then you have the chinese
communist party that is evil that has a
worldview that's confrontational that
wants to dominate the rest of the world
similarly with most muslims they're like
every other human being it's it's their
faith is cultural they turn to god they
they have a certain world view but among
the ordinary muslims you have this
politicized beast called islamism that
is set up
to derail the west that believes in
destroying the state of israel that
undermines women's equality that hates
gay people and wants to destroy every
nation-state in order to create a
great supra islamist caliphate and
that's islamism
distinct from islam the faith now islam
as a faith has many manifestations i
mean the way i see it is a continuation
of the of the old testament and the new
testament you know most muslims believe
in fact all muslims believe in the
jewish prophets the hebrew prophets and
they believe in jesus as the messiah
which distinguishes us from our jewish
friends but they also don't think that
jesus was crucified and they think the
prophet and we believe the prophet
muhammad was also divinely inspired and
the quran is a is a poetic testament to
that so
that's the ordinary muslim and i think
anyone's who's met most muslims or been
to a muslim country will know that
muslims are like anyone else and
hospitable and kind and all of those
traits but islamism much like chinese
communism is the threat that produces
terrorism and that i think is a simple
distinction ed the one thing that leaves
me baffled is uh
i i i kind of understand why if you grew
up in certain countries in the middle
east like my grandfather was originally
from lebanon why you might be
radicalized right particularly you know
when you see the history of that area
what i don't understand a young lads
growing up in london or manchester
growing up in the west and then buying
into this philosophy yeah great question
francis i don't blame the young lad
i blame the rest of us for not having
the confidence to say to the young lad
come on board
this is britain this is how we live here
these are our rules you sign up to them
and you are now a roman citizen that's
how it used to be for the ancient romans
you signed up to roman values spqr the
senate and the people of rome and you
became a roman citizen and the whole
world was your oyster and you had the
protection of rome
and we don't have that confidence we're
busy self-flagellating ourselves for
historical mistakes or otherwise rather
than saying britain's one of the
greatest countries in the world that i
mean i could go and live in china by the
way for 50 years i'd never become
chinese
but you can come here and sign up to
british and broader western values of
reason individualism gender equality and
open society and this is unique here and
it's racial equality and you're british
welcome on board but if you then want to
support terrorism or organizations that
want to undo
the thousand-year-old settlement we have
here from you know
1066 to magna carta to where we are
today
then you don't belong here you know you
belong somewhere else we don't have the
confidence to say that so we've left
people alone and i think the focus on
just oh if you speak english you're fine
well no that's not good enough
you know that's just
the bar is too low so the the battle of
ideas is what's got to be won in other
words if you come here
these are the ideas you sign up for you
then get citizenship in exchange for
that and you love and you're a patriotic
person belonging to this country or this
part of the world the americans do that
generally better than we do um
but but for as long as we don't do that
it's easy i think for
teenagers and others to get sucked in
by whether it's communists islamists or
others so
you know if it has to be a rethinking
and
or not blame shifting but recalibrating
it's on the rest of us who don't share
that extreme ideology to be proud of who
we are as a people and as a nation and
as an island and what we've done for the
rest of the world which brings us neatly
onto your book among the mosques in
which you went out and you went into
mosques around the country and you spoke
to people and you you ask questions
what did you find
i found lots of good things that
surprised me and i think that those
those things ought to be mentioned you
know in a mosque in edinburgh to see a
gay couple sat in a mosque kitchen now
that that really shocked me to go uh
into birmingham and see a lady working
in a clinic for gay people that
surprised me i i
uh to meet young kids in the madras in
dukesbury who are playing with jewish
kids i mentioned that because we judge a
society and its strength by how it
treats its minorities and i think the
ultimate test is how we treat our jewish
cousins and forebears and how we treat
people who have a different lifestyle to
us in the private sphere i.e
homosexuality by those two tests you
know i i was surprised and i was it was
generally heartwarming i didn't expect
that why not because i thought
the perception of
people who were religiously pious was
conservative right as in they would not
be open to
the other
but they were and that's positive and
that's cause for hope that we can
continue to maintain a pluralist free
open
britain and open society
um
by open society i don't mean george
soros
i mean i i mean carl popper i mean
you're hardly a jewish chill here right
yeah
i mean carl popper who who went to new
zealand who loved england for his
openness for standing up against the
nazis yeah i don't mean i don't i don't
mean george sorry i should clarify the
language has become very difficult on
every year i know you say something
people think you mean something else
so you were pleasantly surprised by some
of these things are we going to talk
about the great reset or not
to constantine's question um
but what surprised me was the following
things that
i i often go to synagogues i also go to
churches in the spirit of the you know
the abrahamic faiths that we've all
inherited that have produced these great
civilizations and i hear prayers for her
majesty the queen or in the u.s you know
for the country for the president but i
don't hear those prayers in mosques in
britain and that worries me there's a
disconnect that you know the monarchy
and everything else is somewhere out
there we are an insular different
setting
um so the lack of patriotism
public open patriotism worries me the
second thing that worried me was a focus
on a different legal system so in some
mosques there's an attempt to impose a
sharia law
in in personal elements of people's
lives my fear is it always starts like
that you know you you have a different
legal system for divorce for inheritance
uh and and for you know
matters of how you raise children ed i'm
going to stop you there how does that
work so
if somebody's getting divorced or if
there's there's some kind of altercation
or a perceived injustice has taken place
how does that work with the sharia law
well
if i was if i was a woman a muslim woman
let's say in you know loughborough keith
lee dewsbury bradford i wouldn't be able
to just
readily get a divorce i would need my
husband to issue a divorce for me and in
the absence of doing that i would need
to go to an imam in a court who would
then arbitrate on the on behalf of both
couples and then the imam would issue a
divorce on behalf of the man or say to
me that i'm not
deserving of a divorce for example if my
grounds were that i've been beaten up
and i
i don't want to sustain a relationship
in which there's physical violence that
the imam would rule that it's it's
prescribed in scripture that the man has
the right to beat a muslim woman and
therefore the divorce won't be granted
my point is why should british women
be subject to
any imam foreign or otherwise telling
them their legal rights that are theirs
by birth in other words it's their
decision when they get divorced it's a
british court that decides whether they
get divorced or not and those decisions
are not made in a mosque or any other
place so there's a parallel legal system
in operation here and it's growing and
it's a real threat because it plays on
the identity of a muslim woman is she
muslim or is she british she's british
her being muslim is
is her faith and
her relationship with god if we break
that contract of having one law for one
nation
we are
opening up
conflicts for the future in which
this is how it started in india and
pakistan
this is how it started in parts of
lebanon this is how it starts in parts
of bosnia that you can't maintain one
rule for one nation so then nations
start to start to break away and
i'm not saying this happens today
tomorrow we've got to take a long-range
view on these things and not make the
mistake of so the sharia law was one um
a third was gender segregation you know
we talk about apartheid but the gender
apartheid is a real factor in many of
the mosques women were not allowed to
enter in many of the mosques these are
mosques you know in dewsbury bradford
many of the mosques in which women were
put in these tiny little cupboards at
the top to pray so the gender
segregation factor is real
and i think the fourth fact and perhaps
the most worrying factor is many of the
imams with all respect to them are not
trained to understand a
post-enlightenment post-industrial
modern britain you know they're still
rehashing scripture from the 1840s in
india the diobandi movement
it's the same movement that spurned the
taliban on one side but to be fair they
also have a secular movement in india so
we've got the more extreme version
so those three indicators are real
problems for
right so right now we have 2000 mosques
we have about 4 million muslims now
amplify that in the coming years let's
assume the number of muslims increase in
another in and of itself is that's not a
problem but if we have this kind of
politicized separatist form of religious
identity then i think it's a real
problem because you will see the
political map changing you will see
constituencies and and politicians you
know
trying to garner votes with a certain
type of messaging that leads to a more
separatist more islamist
uh uh worrying britain now the people
may say well i'm being alarmist well i
say to you just two weeks ago you had a
guy from blackburn getting on a plane
going all the way down to texas holding
a synagogue hostage that's from
blackburn i say to you when the israelis
responded to the terrorism out of gaza
we had men from bradford come down into
the finchley road and other parts on a
saturday morning when that when there
are fellow jewish friends of ours and
fellow citizens going to synagogue
addressing them with you know we're
you know
using expletives against them and their
mothers and i could go on and on and on
so we're already seeing separatism
people were driving through north london
yeah with convoy saying rape jewish
women etc right yes you put it politely
they used other words yeah
um so
i think you've worked out by now that
i'm not a scholar of the quran
or of the faith in general but the
question i would ask
is
it it has been said by some people that
the political the merger of politics
with religion
is inseparable within islam
that
it is a political and theological
ideology and
absent a reformation like the christian
faith had it will always be that way
what do you say to those people yeah
that's an interesting argument and i
would say that's a historic argument it
belongs in the history books it belongs
in our past because you can't live 30
million muslims who live in the west
the west is built on secularism
it's built on secular laws and it's
built on nation states
you can't live as a citizen in those
countries and believe that you're now
going to undo secular laws undo
nation-states and bring in some kind of
sharia arrangement if that's what you
want then you know please live in
afghanistan because that's what they're
trying to do over there
because they want to go back to a
different world the world has moved on
now can islam modernize can muslims
modernize absolutely they can and the
best evidence for that is what we're now
seeing in several of the arab gulf
countries
and the best evidence for that is that
we now have 52 muslim nation states
they're not forming a caliphate they
want to be secular nation states the
best evidence for that is those
countries want secular laws other than
afghanistan
not not a single 51
of the other muslim countries you know
want to lash women or want to stone
adulterers or want to bring any of those
holy saudi arabia i don't think women
are
lashed anymore or stoned
but the point is even in saudi arabia
they're trying to reform and modernize
actually i see exactly what you're
saying the only question i would put you
i have a friend who actually trained as
an imam before moving on with his life
and one of the things he always said to
me is
people like you
who are saying we need to move on
you are blaspheming according to the
scripture you are trying to reform a
religion that has very precise
definitions of how you ought to behave
and the idea of reforming is blasphemous
yeah i don't agree i don't think the the
the the muslim record over the last 1400
years agrees in 1857 the ottoman
empire the caliphate decriminalized
homosexuality
you know this is before oscar wilde by
140 years you know so
it's just worth bearing in mind that
there is a long tradition of reform and
change and modernization within islam
i mean the prophet muhammad was supposed
to be a reformer that's the whole point
he had a problem with the doctrine of
the trinity and he was trying to reform
islam began as a reformation it began as
change it began as a renaissance we
can't now become the people who suddenly
are
becoming frozen in time that's not who
we are it's not blasphemous to seek for
change
[Music]
across the muslim world has changed my
fear is that muslims in this country are
stuck in the
1970s imagination of what it means to be
muslim the middle east is changing for
example the abrahamic courts who would
have thought that you would have
peace in the open a warm
lively peace with with israel between
multiple arab nations so my point is
this that reform and change is normal
you know you can either change
edmund burke famous famously said that
in order to conserve you've got to
change a constant conservation depends
on change if you don't change you die
so muslims have got to change and adapt
we saw in the life of the prophet
muhammad he changed from being in mecca
to medina you know we saw his companions
changing when they went from place to
place you know we saw islam in indonesia
is different from in islam in bosnia is
different from islam in nigeria is
different from islam in saudi arabia we
can't now say that in the year 2022 here
in england
we are not going to change and adapt
well then don't come to england because
there's a certain way of doing things
here when you're here you do them as
they're supposed to be done rather than
trying to recreate afghanistan here one
of my mates is is a muslim lad and i was
talking to him about this and he said to
me part of the issue with what we're
seeing in this country francis
is that a lot of poorer people came from
india and pakistan and bangladesh to
this country and they have a far more
conservative version of islam than the
upper and the middle classes in places
like india is that true would you agree
with that that's partly true but it's
not the whole story because
we have people who came from india who
were sikhs and hindus from similar parts
of the subcontinent you know sikhs came
from the punjab muslims also came from
the punjab
hindu similarly came from parts of india
from which muslims also came then it
begs the question why is it that we have
hindus and sikhs we're very patriotic
and generally much more integrated than
parts of bradford and keithley and
you know uh
east london and so on there's something
else going on and it's the question that
we discussed at the outset constantine
islamism
the desire to have a political ideology
make islam your personal faith and love
god as much as you want but when you
make that your political ideology which
you must impose on others you must hate
israel you must dislike
and see women as second class uh
citizens that non-muslims are somehow
filthy and
that that public public politicization
is the problem
if we had to identify one thing it would
be that and then i would also ask the
question
why is it that muslims in america are so
generally much more integrated you know
i i don't want to name names but
someone who i know from here went to
live in america a prominent british
journalist
is a british muslim journalist went to
washington dc went into a mosque to pray
and he was shocked to see that many of
the members of that congregation were
muslims who worked for the cia the state
department the pentagon the u.s army and
he he just
his whole thing was i thought we were
against all of those institutions but
american muslims are american
and they proudly serve in the us armed
forces when we see more and more and
more british muslims serving in the
british armed forces
there are a good 600 or so at the moment
but we need to see that reflected as per
you know four million muslims then you
know that you were making real progress
when muslims start to pray for her
majesty the queen of the royal family
you know we're making real progress when
muslims in britain start to behave like
the united arab emirates and other
countries and make peace with israel and
love their fellow
jewish forebears you know we've made
progress
until those things happen
we have a genuine concern for
what awaits this country
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website well if you do then easy
dns are the company for you easy dns is
the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be council culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows a bit about
that so will you in a second easy dns
have rock-solid network infrastructure
and incredible customer support they're
in your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you'd know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is head over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code which is of course triggered
as well and you will get 50 percent off
the initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy that tells you
everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
ed how much of this is a problem from
rogue imams
preaching this kind of hatred this
intolerance i'll give you an example so
for about three four months when i was
doing supply teaching i was working in
an islamic primary school and
i had a brilliant time actually i really
enjoyed it they were lovely people warm
kind
one of the best schools i've worked in
really really was it was it was lovely
you mentioned there was a lot of
discipline there yeah yeah which i agree
with
no bad thing in a school yeah exactly
exactly he always complains about the
discipline lack of discipline yeah they
were they were behaved actually but
there was only
one incident that caused me real cause
for alarm in that uh three o'clock or
half two they they had an imam come in
to give islamic studies
and he sat these kids down and i was
teaching a year two class at the time it
was covering maternity so how old is
that so year two this is about six and
seven years old right and he sat them
down and these little kids sweet little
kids and he was telling them stories
from the quran all good and then he went
uh and then he told the story about
jesus and why jesus
and the story of jesus and he said to
them jesus was killed because the jews
were jealous of him
and then he and then he repeated it
several times more than was necessary
and i remember watching it and going
what's going on here is it is this
indoctrination
what's happened do you see what i mean i
felt really uncomfortable yeah and i
didn't quite know what i was seeing and
then when you see about these other
rogue imams you think is this what's
happening up and down the country
so i'm sorry you had to encounter that
yeah most muslims don't believe jesus
was killed much less killed by jewish
people so
it's it's strange that this imam would
be
putting out
basically nazi propaganda um you know
we all know that jesus was jewish we all
know that the
new testament was most of his followers
were jewish so it's wrong to just blame
jewish people because you know his
movement was jewish
um
so so
that that aside
rogue imam's yes but i i don't
so i've got to be honest frances i don't
think the problem is with imams yes we
have imams that could be better trained
and yes we could have imams that are
much more patriotic but the imams are
responding to the congregation
because you know
their salaries are raised
you know among the congregants
uh if i had to identify one source where
things need to be addressed
and you're near there which is the
education space you know on our
university campuses we're afraid
to assert you know what would be you
know right values versus wrong values
we're afraid to say
that certain values are yes superior to
other values if you believe you know in
female genital mutilation i'm sorry that
belief is not just inferior
but it's
invalid in the eyes of someone who
believes in gender equality there's a
superior and right value and there's an
inferior incorrect value if we're not
prepared to make that argument then on
university campuses we have this moral
relativism everything's right all values
are the same than art and what that then
produces is a media class and a
political class that won't challenge the
imams
when the imams are saying that a woman
who is beaten up in her marriage seeking
a divorce can't get divorced because
somehow it's scripturally valid
so it's all connected but the the root
of it even for the rogue imams is to do
with what we're teaching
our elites if you like those who are
going to be forming the new cohort of
political and media leaders and i think
so much of that is to do with with with
uh with the university space that needs
to
you know it needs to again you know
remember that the university is is an
outcome of the the the academy that
plato started that the socrates is
student that it was about seeking the
truth it was about philosophy and
reflecting on the world and not
indoctrination
so once that i think is addressed then
then we'll see you know the wider
education system and then the rogue
imams and others are minimizing because
it's all connected
it's all interconnected and and for as
long as we the rest of us don't have
confidence in who we are and asserting
that i don't think we can hold migrant
communities hostage and say oh how did
how dare you believe x y said well no
one told them to think otherwise and no
one explained that in britain you know
women are equal in the eyes of the law
they have
legal status that's
equal to that of a man
they think they're second-class citizens
because no one sat down and said to them
no it's different here so i i blame
ourselves for not getting all this right
before i ask you about how we try to
remedy some of this which i think is
very important obviously the one thing
that strikes me is
i watch i used to not anymore but i used
to watch a lot of tv news night question
time all of that stuff
and i fear that i like many people
listening to this and watching this have
never heard a muslim
on television or on the radio or on
youtube frankly talk the way you're
talking
so when we think about
muslim
we think of someone who newsnight would
have on as a sort of let's trigger
everyone anjem choudary or some rogue
preacher or whatever right i don't think
many people have heard someone who is
muslim come in and talk about gender
equality come in and talk about well
look if you don't like it in this
country and you want to live in a
caliphate well there's some people
trying to make one over there you go
back there and and do do that right
we're not having that conversation
honestly so i'm really grateful that
you're here and we're having this
discussion genuinely
but it does seem to me like what you're
describing is a very serious problem
very serious problem and when you look
at you you talked in one of your
previous interviews about the population
dimension of this
the the native population uh or not the
native whatever you want to call it the
the white british population or the
non-muslim population let's say
is declining is a percentage because
we're not having enough kids the muslim
population is doing great big families
and
if you expand that over time which isn't
a problem in and of itself i agreed in
and of itself fine agreed but what kind
of islam is emerging well right if you
let i don't know what the percentages
are but let's say 0.1 percent of all
british muslims are islamists let's say
for the sake it might be more might be
less i don't do you know
would you have an estimate we don't have
a percentage but what i can tell you is
currently 43 000 people are being
monitored by the intelligence agencies
that's a problem enough right so so
let's say the muslim population grows to
what i think it's like 15 million by
2050 something like that some of the
estimates from the ons which versus four
now so then we might expect uh absent a
significant political change in that era
in the area that it's not going to be 43
000 is gonna be a hundred and thirty
hundred and fifty thousand right so
if this continues the scale of the
problem is going to get bigger yes uh
and the political repercussions of that
you've alluded to are going to get
bigger yes and the violence will get
worse yes right
so what the hell did we do about it well
that's the i mean
you know
you you've you've made my case perfectly
i think you know this is this is the
real issue but thank you for your kind
words this is a real issue
it's not going away we're afraid to talk
about it for fear of allegations of you
know quote-unquote islamophobia
um you know the chinese accuse us of
cynophobia when we talk about communism
you know it's the same thing yeah
russians now got onto on the racket as
well
but
make that up it shuts down conversation
you know yes there's genuine fear and
yes there's you know uh attacks on
muslims and they should be condemned and
they shouldn't happen and every
individual is sacred there's no doubt
about that
but it goes back to us having the
confidence to be able to say what you
just said you know if britain is so
despised by you
please leave
you're not forced to stay here you can
always go to afghanistan or you can go
to the remnants of isis you know
wherever they're you know still
operating in parts of syria or you know
go wherever you want but and may i
interrupt you very briefly i i'd love
you to expand on this but you must know
as someone who used to work in politics
how toxic what you've just said is but
someone's got to say it
someone has got to say it in order to
give our politicians and our media class
confidence over time i'm not seeking
votes i'm not seeking
popularity i seek the truth i love this
country i have two daughters and i want
them to grow up in a country in which
they're not discriminated against i want
them to grow up as proud muslim women
who have the rights as any other woman
as british citizens i don't want them to
marry a man who says to them that oh i
can beat you because it say so in
scripture nor do i want them not to be
able to get a divorce because they're
dependent on some imam nor do i want
them to inherit any less than a than a
son would so for me this is very
personal and i want my children and i
want their generation and others to grow
up as proud westerners and there must be
no conflict between being muslim and
being western and if there is a conflict
then being westerner comes first because
the west is equally islamic in my eyes
and i can make that argument based on
history and scripture there is no
contradiction there is no clash of
civilizations we've got to have the
confidence to say that that this this
part of the world i mean you don't get
to say thomas aquinas without avarois or
may monadies you know and without that
you don't have the reformation and where
we ended up now
with the enlightenment
so we've got to stop saying that we're
somehow at clash once that's done and we
agree that muslims belong here as
westerners
with equal rights but sign up to the
western values you know stop trying to
subvert them
then what we're in a position to to do
is to tell give our politicians that
confidence
which is what they don't have we haven't
won the argument yet and i think once
we've won the this argument that we're
having now because ultimately we will
and we must for the for
the safety security prosperity of this
country in this part of the world we
must
every other option is a non-option for
us you know there there isn't going to
be a harmonious coexistence in parts of
blackburn there just isn't you've got to
win this argument and people who want to
live a separate life have got to decide
whether they want to be in this country
or somewhere else otherwise it causes
genuine long-term uh
clashes and conflicts that are not in
the interests of any quote-unquote
community you know i hate that term by
the way
um because we're in we're individuals
we're citizens and where we're in this
country you know subjects and another
country citizens so that's the first
point the second point is the education
issue you know uh whether it's at school
level or whether it's at university
level this has got to be addressed that
what britain is as a
as its own history what it is in terms
of i mean i call it rigor
reason individualism gender equality the
open openness of this country for free
speech and free press
it's uniqueness and racial equality
every one of those facets are opposed by
islamists and communists by the way
and that's why those six
letters or ideas that form the acronym
rigor inform us and and come hello high
water we mustn't compromise on a single
one of those and now there's hegelian
dialectic where you just compromise and
find a third way now we've come to this
point through a lot of blood and through
a lot of treasure being sacrificed in
two world wars yeah no i i agree with
you i agree with you completely and by
the way your point about the fact that
there is no clash of civilizations it's
been echoed by many of our previous
guests who we've talked amon dean former
al-qaeda uh informer turned started
working for mi5 and and many others
to explain to us what you said which is
the conflict isn't between islam and the
west the conflict is between islamists
who hate the nation state and wanna
caliphate and everybody else yes which
is why they're not only blowing up
people in this country they're blowing
people all over all over the middle east
have died of course yes that's because
they want those nation states not to
exactly either right exactly so i get
all that my question to you and
i i trust me i fear what you fear as
much as you fear it
and i see it coming as much as you see
it coming because it's obvious once you
start playing identity politics in this
way the end is obvious into tribal
conflict it's inevitable
but you can say this because you're a
muslim
and because you're brown i can say
because i'm an immigrant and because i
have dark skin and i can go well as an
immigrant i actually you know if
russians in this country said we need to
make this the greater russia and live by
russian standards and adopt the orthodox
christian religion i'd be like why don't
you [ __ ] off back to russia
that's what i would say and i'd be okay
to say that
but francis wouldn't
right
and i'm not saying people shouldn't say
because we should be able to as
individuals as patriots as citizens take
a position that's of relevance to our
individuality our citizenship in our
country regardless i mean martin luther
king's the content of your character not
to judge that was his dream not to be
judged by the color of your skin
and that's who we are we can't we can we
had two black roman emperors you know
the romans had that they were a hot spot
of you know and that's who we are that's
what makes us unique and different and
open and special so how do we get there
this is what i'm asking but continue to
defend the enlightenment heritage that
we have you know those of us who want to
conserve liberalism or the enlightenment
tradition and that's what it is we we
can't i think we're doing it now that
we're defending our inheritance and we
refuse to give up i refuse to be seen
just as someone with a certain skin tone
or just as my gender judge me by my
content of what i'm saying and my
character and my behavior don't judge me
by
because otherwise we're undoing martin
luther king you know we're undoing all
those people who died and it's got to be
done by us doing what we're doing but
defending it by not cow towing but not
doing the tribalism you know
um and ultimately
you know in the long term it's got to be
winning the political argument reform on
our university campuses
and by by winning the battle of ideas
among muslim communities and others and
i think forgive me for being an optimist
i think we are i think i don't think
we're losing this what do you have i
think we're well the evidence is
for us winning
well i think you know you're seeing even
from
uh david cameron to angela merkel to
boris johnson to
macron these are all centrist political
figures
who have thrown out the baby of
multiculturalism
you know they they they realize that you
know you you can't just say we're we're
all the same
so so that that's now
yeah that's a positive sign
the second positive sign is that there
are many more muslims who are making the
kind of arguments that i am and people
from other
faith backgrounds
and the third argument is i think i i
always judge something historically and
now by the way in which we're treating
jewish people because they're you know
they're an ancient
people who've been with us for six
thousand years and everyone who's
mistreated them has got it wrong over
the years
so how muslims interact with the jewish
state is absolutely vital you know
israel was so isolated just five years
ago and now we're seeing a greater
acceptance of israel which bodes well
for the future of the middle east but we
haven't seen that here yet and i think
that's another positive sign a fourth
sign if i have is the defeat of jeremy
corbyn you know that's got to be a good
sign that we were on the cusp of an
anti-semite
taking power
and labor party one of one of our great
political parties taken hostage by these
you know the the ugly alignment of the
far left
and
and islamists defeated roundly you know
so i think those are those are signs
that we must and you know my teacher
roger scrutin used to say that you know
we must always be optimistic otherwise
we run the risk of
talking ourselves down and embracing
embracing a negative future and we
mustn't and we can't
ed it's it's such a brilliant
conversation i'm really enjoying it we
had ed weston the journalist who and he
made the point and it's something that
struck me
and i always think about it actually
that if you don't talk about taboo
subjects honestly
then what happens is you're never going
to find the solution to the problem
because you're not discussing the
problem in an honest and frank fashion
and you're not dealing with all the
facets of the problem
my worry is is that we continue along
this route where we have taboos and what
always happens in this situation is you
get nefarious figures from the far right
who will come along and go look they're
not talking about it but i'm going to
and that can start a movement and what
happens at that point is that
you're in a really dangerous situation
yes because what you're doing is just
collecting tinder by not talking about
it and eventually something's going to
happen there's going to be a spark
whether it be a terrorist incident or
something else
and we're going to we're going to be in
a very dangerous place absolutely right
and that's not too exaggerated
whatsoever you know it it
it takes just one or two incidents to
create i mean
i mean i i could
you know in my mind you know serbia
comes to mind no one thought that
serbian nationalism would trigger the
first world war but it did you know
in france now you've got someone from
the far right who's a serious political
contender again this is the fourth
french general election in which there
is someone from the far right that's a
popular contender and britain has been
very blessed over the last millennium
that we don't have extremist political
forces you know but we shouldn't take
that for granted the english-speaking
world is genuinely at risk with this
issue so we should speak about taboo
subjects i mean since when did we stop
pursuing truth
since when did we stop having a battle
of ideas and we got to where we got to
by discussing
taboo subjects the enlightenment was
exactly that you know having a reasoned
conversation with religious clerics and
others in order to get beyond dogma now
we can't having got here after 500 years
of people dying
and which is being burned and heretics
being
killed
uh you know civil wars and world wars we
can now we can't now say we've got a new
set of dogmas and please we're not going
there no we are we're going everywhere
there's going to be free conversation
based on respect but pursuit of truth
but the use of free reason without which
we're lost we're going back in time it's
regression
and our forefathers you know many
muslims and others died in both world
wars you know didn't fight two world
wars for a free world in order for their
grandchildren us
now to be captured again for a new set
of dogmas where as you say taboo
subjects are off the table they mustn't
be
but you work in a university ed you must
have seen with your own eyes how
freedom of speech has been degraded you
know students complaining that they need
to feel safe etc etc people being
de-platformed yeah i i i work at
georgetown university in washington dc
and i've got to say in all honesty i
haven't faced any of those difficulties
i honestly haven't
i teach a course on western civilization
and islam and judaism and how the three
forces over time gave us the modern
world
and uh you know i defend the west i
explain the west my students are there
part of the security studies program to
then go out many of them have done
active duty in afghanistan iraq and
elsewhere so i mean it's the real world
stuff and i've got to say i haven't yeah
you're not dealing with pink head 18
year olds though are you the
postgraduates
and you're not talking about the trans
issue
they're all welcome they're all welcome
they are all welcome because they too
deserve to be in these classes in order
to have those conversations you know
i also cut some slack to the younger
generation i think you're allowed to be
a you know
blue headed or pink head whatever it is
for a period of period of time
and then you grow up right you grow up
you realize the real world and then you
start to appreciate
the inheritance that we have
i mean stephen pink is completely right
on by every measure where we were just
200 years to where we are now you know
we can only give gratitude to the past
to where we've arrived
and
how much of a problem do you think is
the narrative and look
the narrative has got a certain merit to
it you know that america are the
oppressors what they've done in places
like iraq syria has caused untold
suffering
they had no business being there how
much of a part has that played in
radicalizing young men
it's had some i mean they that those are
grievances that are used right but 9 11
happened before syrian before iraq
you know in 1993 omar abdul rahman the
blind sheikh from you know egypt was
involved in the world trade center this
is 1993 after the west had got involved
in bosnia against the serbs and other
christian nations you know so i these
are all ideological kind of issues that
they use to mobilize people the real
issue at the at the crux of it is that
there is a movement out there just like
the chinese communist people hide among
ordinary chinese people islamists hide
among ordinary muslims and it is that
force that's active in 52 muslim
countries that seeks to destabilize as
you rightly said constantine those
countries first and foremost you know
over 45 000 pakistanis have been killed
by the the pakistani taliban and to do
away with those nation states and that
secular settlement and before it comes
here so it's that ideology which we've
got to defeat and the good news is this
we have defeated other ideologies and we
have won but the way we've done that yes
you know the the radio free europe and
so on those are all tactics but we have
got to assert and retain and defend and
be proud of who we are
if we're if we're not going to defend
who we are i mean hillary elder used to
say this the great jewish rabbi that
you know if a nation doesn't know who it
is and defend itself it doesn't it
doesn't deserve survival
that's a strong warning to who we are if
we want to continue to be the world's
top dog we've got to know and defend and
pass on this heritage to our children
again you know edmund burke was
brilliant at this you know that
society is is a contract between the
past the present and the yet unborn
i mean this this is this is our heritage
we have got to defend it for if we don't
nobody else will
and but the problem is so you you've got
this very small sliver of society now
you can say to them look if you're not
happy here go
but but what do you do with them
really because if you put them into
prison they not only they not only
become even more radicalized they
radicalize other people you know what
was interesting francis is the strongest
reaction that we've seen from that camp
that small camp you've identified was
when pretty patel threatened to remove
their citizenship
that's the thing that gets to the most
because they realize they're operating
under the
banner of of british protection the
moment you remove that protection you
start seeing them getting edges the only
time i've seen them in the last 15 years
mounted
a serious challenge to that way of
thinking
which tells us it hurts them which tells
us that it worries them so in the
meantime i think that's exactly the way
to go that if
you
are
we have a word for it's called treason
you know we've had it on the
on the books for more than 600 years
um if you commit acts of treason there
will be repercussions in a free and fair
society you mean of course you can
question
you know our direction of travel and of
course you can question you know certain
social practices i think we're all we're
all aghast that we you know we have a
culture of people getting drunk and
vomiting on the streets we want to we
all want to see a better country but
let's work on this together rather than
saying the entire west is at fault and
therefore we're going to blow you up um
and if people are of that persuasion
then we have you know we've got to make
being in britain for that type of person
unwelcome
and do do you think are you in favor of
stripping citizenship sorry for instance
in the case of shamima begum are you in
favor of
uh well shamima begum i'm afraid i am
because she made a conscious decision
and she went even though she made it as
somebody 15 underage under legal age etc
cetera but i don't think i don't think
we've seen genuine contrition from her
you know i i i still i have a problem
with the kind of people that are
representing her
you know i don't want to sound libelous
here but but
there are genuine issues as to the kind
of people that are representing and the
kind of arguments that they're making
and then and the lack of contrition you
know you know wearing western clothes
isn't contrition you know there's
uh
there's an ongoing legal process and
let's not get into that but the point is
you know chama is a reminder to millions
of muslims as to how great this country
is that she wants to come back
uh you know she's she's not saying that
she wants to go
to afghanistan
so
so but here's the problem and you as an
educator on this i'm sure you've
grappled with this question i i doubt
i'm the first person to ask you this but
this is the problem of a tolerant
societies if you become too tolerant
then the intolerant people within the
society will triumph
but to a british
listener hearing the idea that we might
take someone who's here in the third
generation
who's never been to any other country
other than britain who hates this
country who's maybe committed violence
here
to strip them of their citizens isn't
that unbritish no
it's very british very british in the
sense that um
your citizenship is something that's
dependent on you having a contract with
the rest of society where you don't go
around killing them destroying them
undermining what this country is all
about when
that's why we have something called the
treason laws and every year we celebrate
guy fawkes night because he was a
catholic terrorist trying to blow up
parliament guy fawkes remembering that
moment is among the most british things
to think to do you know so i don't think
it's unbritish to say if you want to
blow up parliament and we've had four
attacks in the last 10 years on
parliament from islamist extremists if
you want to remove the british freedom
of women to wear whatever they want
whenever they want however they want
wherever they want if you want to kill
our jewish citizens who contributed to
this country from 1070 with william the
conqueror all the way to israeli and
onwards
you're not part of us and the way you're
not part of us is that you no longer
enjoy the privileges of a british
passport and british citizenship now
it's it's obviously got to be violent
and it's got to be active i mean someone
who's
questioning all of that is
they're fully within their rights as was
jeremy corbyn to want to make friends
with the ira and want to make friends
with hamas and hezbollah you're fully
within your rights to be a dissenter but
when you take up arms and when you
undermine you know us our people our
institutions and then you join forces
with our enemies to destroy our soldiers
british soldiers who are putting their
lives at risk so that all of us can
sleep
at home peacefully at night that's not
british and the way you punish that is
by removing
the very documents and the very
privileges that allows you to commit
treason against us i know you know guy
fawkes is the best example that comes to
my mind so i guess what you're saying we
should deal with acts of political
terrorism differently as we would with
common criminals so if someone
you know if there's a stabbing incident
on the street we don't deport people for
engaging in that but if you are engaging
in that for political purposes as an act
of intimidation of terrorism etc you you
consider that a different issue they've
been there there have been several
islamist terrorist plots against
the monarchy
against the prime minister against the
foreign secretary against parliament
[Music]
three parliamentarians have been
attacked
i mean this in the last 15 years
what more do we need before we say when
you act against the country its
institutions its history its symbols and
you attack
our most treasured minority communities
i.e jewish communities and you know
we've had suicide bombers from here
going going and attack israel
what at what point do we say enough and
i think that point is here and i think
this point is now and i think priti
patel is right to want to remove
citizenship from people who don't want
that citizenship who hate that
citizenship who speak out against their
citizenship and commit acts of violence
against our greatest people our armed
forces
and we've got to be able to make that
argument with complete confidence
you know a lot of mainstream people
watch our show
and i hope they're listening because i
don't know i haven't thought as deeply
as you have about this and
instinctively i am quite uncomfortable
with the idea of stripping people of
national even from my own perspective
you know i've made my home here my life
here i kind of like to think that even
if i make a mistake now this is more
than making a mistake to be fair i i can
i can stay here and serve my people what
if you took up arms and decided to want
to you know i should [ __ ] off back to
russia there's no question about that so
that i i think most common sense
oriented people would agree with this
line of reasoning right so what i'm
saying otherwise we don't have a country
left because those numbers agree and
institutions are attacked you know i
agree so i hope that the mainstream
people who watch our show and
politicians who watch our show
take note of what you're saying and give
you a bigger platform i also think
you're ahead of the curve i think you
know as a year
and i think we're at least 10 15 years
ahead people will come to this
argument in time look what's happening
in france yeah in belgium in holland and
across the continent and you know we've
always been outliers in the continent in
more ways than one and we've got to win
this issue on our terms rather than be
this is my big concern ed is that i hope
that the people
who
hear this and listen to this and who
come in the future to addressing this
issue because it needs addressing
there's no question about it
address it from your position
because for me the fear of having these
conversations has always been the same
which is
you are
emboldening people that you don't want
to embolden sometimes you're giving
a voice to to people who who want
conflict this is the problem right
there's a lot of people you see it with
covet now and i know that you've tried
to stay the hell away from it and
actually you've made the right decision
but there are people now who are pro
restrictions and anti-restrictions who
really want covert to carry on because
it gives them meaning it gives them
purpose it gives them validity gives
them a platform it gives them all of
that an identity and identity as well
and that's my fear and that's why again
i'm so grateful that you're here and
we're having this conversation because
there's ways to have this conversation
that are very destructive
i think
i agree and it's it's a difficult
conversation to have because it is about
identity heritage faith emotions and
that's why we've got to be reasonable
about it
and i i
the thing i think most people won't
understand is the people who stand to
gain most out of us getting this right
is muslims
and especially muslim women you know who
are currently you know who get married
at a mosque and want to go for a divorce
and suddenly realize they don't have any
rights because they didn't register
their marriage you know over a hundred
thousand of those marriages are going on
now so a muslim woman coming in say from
pakistan or any other country has rights
because
under our laws we recognize those
marriages but if a muslim woman born and
raised in this country a british
national gets married here at a mosque
she doesn't have any rights as a as a
married woman because the law doesn't
currently recognize
uh you know sharia marriages because we
don't recognize sharia law so
if we get this right it's muslims who
win it's the very country that our
forefathers came to is protected it's a
win-win situation we get this wrong it's
muslims who suffer most the so-called
islamophobia is harmful most to muslims
but overall we all benefit because this
you know we all love this country and we
we
cherish the air and the soil in which we
walk in the countryside and it's
beautiful we want to maintain that
so and do not worry that with the
stripping of the citizenship and the
british passport that it potentially
creates a two-tier society because
there's some people who will engage in
acts of terrorism et cetera et cetera
but because
their br their their english for five
generations or whatever it may be
they won't face the same punishment
i i don't think it only becomes a
two-tier society when it's a widespread
uh
problem when you've got tens of
thousands of people i don't think that's
what we're looking at if we get this
right if we get it now
worst case scenario i think we're
looking at a couple of hundred three
hundred people you know but if we let
this fester
that's when we end up in a
two-tiered society and that's why we
shouldn't get there we should address
this now before it gets out of out of
out of control and i think it's
imminently doable
now we may feel squeamy about this but i
put it to you that every other
alternative is far worse
agreed
the only problem is the way our politics
works is people don't deal with problems
until they become far worse
in which case
it's far worse looks ugly it does it
looks bloody it looks
i mean it looks in parts of the north in
particular
you know horrendous when you look at it
i'd encourage people in the south to go
go up to blackburn you know
go up to dewsbury and and come and tell
me that's england and what will they see
i think parts of dewsbury industry not
didsbury because i got into trouble with
the daily mail who've got jewsbury and
didsbury didsbury's fine other than a
moth that produced the guys who
you know the guys who prayed there uh
went and uh you know one one guy in
particular who used to pray at dinsbury
mosque was involved with the ariana
grande concert think about that ariana
grande's concert attacked by a guy who
prayed at a particular mosque i go to
that mosque and i still see some of the
extremist literature you know that was
used then used now
um and it has a sharia court too you
know so
that's what the future looks like if we
don't get it right but i think in parts
of dewsbury what people will see is uh
you know
areas that look more like afghanistan
and they should be rightly worried about
that
you know
[Music]
why should i why should i go
to a mosque in blackburn or keithley and
see
um the palestinian slogans and support
for hamas
how does that work you know you got
peterborough nearby with much bigger
issues why are you focused on a conflict
about which you have
zero involvement why should i go in to a
a book shop
in
um
walsall
and
read literature that's being sold that
denigrates gay people and women and
jewish people
i mean i could go on and on i'd
encourage people to read the book i
haven't plugged the book in the way that
americans plug books all the time saying
read my book read my book read more but
i i mean i've documented it all and it's
it's in the book and i think you know
those who care about the future of the
of of this country should read it and
defend it with every fiber of their
being muslims and others are welcome to
this country you know it's not putting
up the barriers and they
come on board
but as the ancient romans did you know
become roman
don't try and undermine and subvert a
beautiful country and a civilization
that's welcoming you giving you shelter
comfort
and and your children prosperity
that's a beautiful note to finish on and
i really admire your spirit of optimism
as well and i agree with you
temperamentally if not intellectually
anyway
i share your optimism but we'll see
whether either of us is right and it's
been a pleasure the book is called among
the mosques and i do genuinely of course
recommend that people get it and read it
because i think they'll get a deeper
insight into many of the things you're
talking about but as ever we've got one
more question for you which is always
what's the one thing we're not talking
about but we really should be
christianity
christianity it's it's the heritage
that has made this part of the world
different
from other countries and other parts of
the world because it's with christianity
you get individualism because it breaks
from you know inherited religiosity
and there's i mean
one of the things that roger said when i
last met him roger scrutin i remember
seeing sitting beside him in his country
farm and he said that
you know
the the teaching that jesus gave in
terms of
rendering
unto god what is god and unto caesar
what is caesar's made this part of the
world different the bedrock of
secularism now love each other as i've
loved you you know the bedrock of
forgiveness and inclusivity
and um you know the
those two teachings in particular but i
mean i could go on but i don't want to
kind of upset people uh
with
the whole kind of crucifixion and people
get upset because and the trinity but
but
the point is we don't have to talk about
jesus constantly in those terms he was
and remains probably the greatest
teacher that humanity has ever had and i
think here in the west our distance from
christianity
is creating
some of the dissonance that we're seeing
now because we've forgotten notions of
forgiveness so part of the identity
politics and cancer culture is that you
know once someone's committed a blunder
well what's their way back
we don't have redemption left anymore um
hence i think that the talk and
remembrance of the heritage that this
country and other countries indeed have
from christianity is important because
without that spiritual
energy giving
force
we will continue to stray away from the
the great heritage that has been passed
on to us by
christians and others of the past
ed thank you so much if people want to
find you online where's the best place
to do that twitter i think is probably
where i'm most active from time to time
okay thank you guys for having uh ed and
uh at what is it
uh
underscore hussein with one s
you know uh we'll make sure to put that
in the description and uh the link to
the book as well of course thank you
you've both been fantastic by the way
and keep up the excellent work that you
do really appreciate that we're going to
ask you a couple of exclusive questions
for our supporters only uh but for now
thank you so much and thank you guys for
watching and listening we will be back
very soon with another brilliant episode
like this one or raw show all of them go
out at 7 pm uk time and for those of you
who like your trigonometry on the go
it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys
how much do muslim community leaders in
inverted commerce actually reflect the
opinions and values of british muslims